what's up guys bang-bang hope you guys
are doing well we'll wait a few minutes
here to get some some people in before
we get started I think we're gonna have
the number of people kind of trickling
in but I'm gonna spend some time today
talking about what happened in the
economy this week what happened in
financial markets and then we'll be able
to cover hopefully a whole bunch of
questions that you guys may have feel
free to leave comments over here in the
comment section with your questions I'll
do my best to answer as many of those as
I possibly can it's 5 o'clock now
Eastern Time on Friday April 17th
I will go try to go for about an hour so
that's right bang bang let's get started
to begin with there was the payroll
protection program that was announced as
part of the 2 trillion dollar stimulus
plan that stimulus plan was supposed to
save the economy right if you remember
there was a bunch of focus on the
various organizations and lawmakers that
went into creating this program there
was to be 2 trillion dollars they were
gonna bail out Wall Street they were
gonna bail out Airlines they were gonna
bail out small businesses they're gonna
bail out individuals everyone's gonna
get a bailout what ended up happening
was about 350 billion dollars ended up
being available for small businesses in
this payroll protection program and the
details are quite nuanced but
essentially if you were a business and
could show that you were being affected
by coronavirus you could apply starting
last Friday as part of that application
they would give you money and the whole
goal was you had to keep your employees
right one way to prevent economic
collapse or to prevent a bunch of job
loss is to give the employers money the
employers duty to pay the employees only
problem with that we started last Friday
it was mass [ __ ] chaos Thursday night
the rules were given to the banks
the banks had a bunch of questions
Friday morning rolled around most of the
banks didn't even get started actually
processing any of the loans there was
like every time a new bank would come
online it was newsworthy to give you a
sense most banks couldn't process some
banks even said don't even send us the
applications right now we can't process
this we're not willing to process this
and so it was just mass chaos and this
was all thrown together some of it is
because it's urgent
but also it just didn't flow well for
small businesses and so what ended up
happening was it was on a first-come
first-served basis and so whoever got
their applications in first at the banks
they had the best opportunity to go
ahead and get the loan and so the was
really kind of shady weird things going
on so a bank may say hey we are taking
loan applications but we're only gonna
process the ones or accept the ones of
people who are customers of our bank and
have already taken a loan from us right
things like that some of it was to
expedite their underwriting process on
there and some of it was just dumb Bank
bureaucracy but long story short
lots of people applied literally
hundreds of thousands of applications
suppose it came in trillion plus dollars
of applications and as of yesterday
morning Thursday morning around 10:30 11
o'clock the payroll protection program
ran out of money now remember the
Federal Reserve has you know made a
spectacle of running around saying they
have infinite money they're willing to
print as much as needed all right to
ensure that they can inject liquidity
into the market they have infinite money
whatever it takes all these terms that
we've heard them say but what ended up
happening here is they only allocated
350 billion dollars and so it took less
than one week literally took less than a
week and small businesses around the
country ate up all the money right and
so what ends up happening is the data
that I recently saw was only 3% of small
business applications actually got
accepted and everyone else was just out
of luck so 97% of businesses are out of
luck they just there's no money for
their massive right now now there will
be more money on the way it sounds like
that process is underway it's not going
to happen today here on Friday and so
we'll see how
that takes but what ends up being really
kind of sad about all this is we already
bailed out we somehow found money to
bail out the airlines and other
industries and give money to hedge funds
and do all this other stuff but small
businesses the people who are the
backbone of American economy the people
who employ millions of American workers
they don't have the money because we
didn't give them enough right three
hundred fifty billion dollars they don't
have it and so what ends up occurring
here is 3% got processed three hundred
fifty billion dollars is now allocated
and you got ninety seven percent of the
people who are saying I need the money
they're not there that there's no money
for them and what's really really shitty
about this right and and just boils my
blood I was talking to one of my
partner's Jason Williams about this and
he's probably even more upset about than
I am is there's a lot of businesses
they're doing unethical things right and
what I mean by unethical is there's a
lot of people applying for the loans
that don't need it so there was reports
that hedge funds and private equity
firms they're reporting it well guess
what their businesses aren't hurt most
of them have capital locked up and
they're giving management fees and so
literally there's little to no change to
their revenue but they're applying and
receiving the loans right and so why
should they get money when small
businesses and Main Street businesses
there's no money left for them as of
right now or how about Harvard and other
universities who ain't applied Harvard
received nine million dollars Harvard
has a forty billion dollar endowment
Harvard does not need the American
taxpayers money
in fact Harvard doesn't pay taxes on a
lot of that endowment money and so
Harvard now is saying not only do we not
have to pay and contribute to the
country because we're at higher
education but instead you're actually
gonna give us money even though we have
this forty billion dollars sitting here
and so what you start to see is there
has to be a question and and really it's
the responsibility of every American to
sit and say why are we allowing these
people who is very obvious don't need
the money to apply for these loans when
real small businesses around the country
need help but now the money's gone and
it just goes back to the same thing
how did Harvard get their money well
because they've got a staff that can go
ahead and process this and they get that
process that paperwork process and
therefore they're one of the first ones
in they get accepted and they get their
money but the small businesses down the
street doesn't get the money three
hundred fifty billion dollars gone in
less than a week but Harvard private
equity firms hedge funds etc they all
got their money they got their loans
right and so what ends up happening is
it's not just we need more money for
small businesses if we are going to
enter a world where the government is
going to bail out or provide relief to
corporations and to businesses there has
to be way more of it right and what's
gonna end up happening here is whatever
number they come up with next another
350 billion five hundred a trillion
dollars it's not gonna be enough or they
are going to have to go down this
slippery slope of producing literally
trillions of dollars just for small
businesses across the country and so
when you get into that world what
happens then is how do you distribute
that money and you know Mark Cuban had a
great point on on Twitter earlier today
he said look we need to go to a lottery
system this whole idea that whoever gets
to apply first whoever you know is
quicker on their trigger finger to
actually submit the application it's
like getting in line well why is it not
a lottery system where the the playing
fields even any American business is
available in order to receive these
loans and we do in some sort of
randomized fashion right and so it's not
so much a game of speed but it ends up
becoming much more fair across the board
and so I think that what we're seeing
with the PPP program is obviously it is
providing some value right look I know
plenty of businesses that got some of
that money but I know a lot more that
didn't and they're sitting in the queue
and they're sitting there wondering what
the hell is going on you got to remember
we're now about four weeks into this
government mandated shutdown and so as
we've seen most small businesses have
anywhere between two to three weeks of
cash some have a month worth of cash but
they're now getting depleted right the
first week okay I got some cash in the
bank the second week are and I got fired
some of my employees so I got a little
bit more runway I've got good through
the second week maybe I got some rate
rent abatement or forbearance
deferrals for my landlord etc now we're
in week four at the end a week four
people are running that Akash and so
what that leads to is two things one
these businesses really need this money
there's families that are dependent on
these small businesses for their income
for their livelihood and those
individuals don't have access to cash
right now
and so when we got to get them money but
to is it feeds into this other thing
which is we're starting to see social
unrest around the country we're starting
to see protests happen because people
are saying it is my constitutional right
to run my business let me run my
business open up the economy and so
we've seen this in state after state
after state I think we've seen him in
North Carolina Kentucky Ohio Minnesota
etc where people are getting pissed off
but we're only in week four it's not
like we've been doing this for you know
three months six months or a year four
weeks in and all of a sudden people are
saying hey we're running out of money
and so there's a saying that you know I
used to hear all the time in the
military which is you look at war and
you always wonder what why do people do
what they do at war meaning not the
American military but but other people
in other areas of the world and the
saying was fear effect refrain from
feeding a man for three days and he'll
do anything right which essentially
means when somebody is hungry or has no
capital and is desperate and has no
other option they're capable of anything
right and you see in war combat zones
you see people kill other people and and
commit crimes and do all these things
otherwise great people who would never
do that but when their back is against
the wall they do desperate things you
see what we're starting to see now is a
sense of desperation spreading across
the United States because the government
has mandated the shutdown of hundreds of
thousands of small businesses and not
only do they shut them down and it's now
been about a month they've run out of
cash but also the payroll protection
program and other types of relief are
not getting to these people but Harvard
got their money hedge funds and private
equity got their money these small
businesses didn't and so what I think
you that then parlays into is we've seen
an explosion in the unemployment numbers
so payroll protection money is gone in
less than a week what happened in the
unemployment number over the last
this week on thursday 5.2 million
americans filed for unemployment claims
that was a report in the last week that
gets added to about 16 million americans
who had filed in the three weeks
previous so that puts the total number
over the last month to about 22 million
americans that have filed for
unemployment in a month
remember we ended February of 2020 at
3.5% unemployment a historic low which
meant about 5.8 million Americans were
out of a job
unless they're in about a month right
six weeks from there but really the last
month that has accelerated and we are
now seeing 22 new million Americans that
are unemployed so you take that 22 and
you add it to this 5.8 million you get
about 28 million Americans right now
that are unemployed that's the reported
number that doesn't represent all the
people who are trying to file claims and
haven't been able to that doesn't
represent all the people who are gig
workers freelancers self-employed etc so
the reported numbers 28 million
Americans I don't got a 165 million in
the workforce that puts unemployment
somewhere around 16% right now if you go
back in the Great Depression in 1929
we started 1929 at a 3.1 percent
unemployment rate which was the historic
low that so three point one percent in
1929 seems pretty similar to the end of
February twenty twenty three point five
percent in 1929 towards the end is when
the Great Depression started we then got
in the next year 1930 a eight point six
or eight point seven percent
unemployment rate and then in 1931 kind
of two years into the depression we got
finally over fifteen percent
unemployment and then finally in 1932 is
when we broke into the 20% unemployment
range well look at what just happened
here in the United States right now
because of the government mandated
shutdown of businesses we went from 3.5%
at the end of February to now we're
sitting at 16% six weeks later it's just
like the virus everyone was worried
about the exponential growth of the
virus spreading and infecting people but
we're having in the unemployment number
is this
acceleration of the number right
whenever you see a number go from 3.5 to
16% that quickly it's not gonna slow
down tomorrow right it's actually gonna
continue like this until we get these
people relief until we turn back on the
economy that is the solution to the
economic crisis you have to turn back on
the American economy you have to get
people back to work
that's how you solve unemployment you
put people to work you don't solve
unemployment by giving people money you
put people back to work and that's being
lost in the conversation I understand
that there's a virus I understand that
there's this health crisis and yes we
need to address that health crisis we
need to open up the economy in a safe
and intelligent way but the way that you
solve unemployment is you put people
back to work it is not rocket science
it's very simple if people don't have a
job get them a job open up the
businesses and put people back to work
that's how you solve unemployment so
we've gone from 3.5 to 16% it's going to
continue to get worse if we do not act
and reopen the economy my guess is that
we could see 20% unemployment by the end
of q3 and even possible to see by the
end of q2 of this year by the end of
June so this is a really bad situation
because remember not only are you now
gonna have tens of millions of Americans
unemployed you then also have the small
businesses who have no access to capital
no access to help they're not getting a
bailout like the corporations or Wall
Street's getting and so what you're
doing is you're sowing this feeling of
unrest this feeling like in 2008 in 2009
who did everyone blame for their
problems they blamed the banks it was
very easy hey there's a housing crisis
that housing crisis caused the global
financial crisis and that global
financial crisis cost me my job my home
you know whatever happened to me
financially I traced that back and I
blame the banks the banks are the reason
why the global financial crisis happened
in many people's eyes and so that
manifests itself in things like Occupy
Wall Street and other types of movements
that were very anti Bank the problem
that we're gonna see here is when you go
through that same exercise and you trace
back who is responsible for this people
are going to point their fingers at the
government they're going to say the
reason why I lost my job or the reason
why my business is not running is
because the government mandated I shut
it down and so you saw an Ohio for
example a hairdresser along with a law
firm filed a lawsuit challenging whether
this is constitutional or not
I predict that is one of many many
lawsuits around the country that we're
going to see but even though those legal
battles are going to be fought and those
legal battles are going to play out what
is more telling is again in week four of
a government mandated shutdown multiple
states are reporting that they are
having protests of people sometimes
armed actually going out and saying it
is our right to go to work it is our
right to go out in public it is our
right to free assembly and therefore
that is what we are going to do now how
the government responds to this is going
to be very tricky because what ends up
happening here is there's a health
crisis but you also can't blatantly
violate the Constitution and so it's one
of these highly complex situations we'll
see how it plays out but you've got a
health crisis creating an economic
crisis that economic crisis is now
introducing the danger of social unrest
and so we have to solve the health and
economic crisis it has to be addressed
because if you don't address the health
and economic crisis then you will get
the social unrest and so if we go and we
talk about the health crisis here is a
very matter-of-fact conversation I want
to start the conversation around the
health crisis with a caveat or a
disclaimer I think that the virus is
real I think that the virus is very bad
there's no doubt in my mind that the
virus has to one be contained - that it
is killing people and three should be
taken seriously with all of that said
every single number that you are reading
about the virus is not true and that's a
bold claim to make but here's my
reasoning for take New York City for
example New York has no clue how many
people are infected with the virus
why we don't have enough testing we
literally could not tell you how
many people are infected with kovat 19
nobody knows and they have predictions
or estimations what they don't know
because there's not enough testing and
then most people will say well that's
just the infected number but we do know
how many people are done well actually
what happened this week was New York
City or New York State is now starting
to count anyone who it is probable that
they had the virus as part of the death
count and now what does that mean it
means that if you died in the last week
two weeks three weeks whatever even if
you did not test positive for kovat 19
they don't know if you hadn't or not but
they think you might have had it you get
counted in the death rate and the reason
why that's a problem is because again if
you think of this as a numerator and a
denominator the numerator being well how
many people died and the denominator
being how many people were infected both
of those numbers are inaccurate and so
all of the predictions that are being
made all of the analysis all of the
decision making is being made off bad
data and people will say what's the best
we have it's a good estimation etc
that's fine it may be true right it
probably is true but what ends up
occurring is we're making decisions off
bad data and the crazy thing is the more
testing we do the lower the death rate
gets and it's because there's actually a
very high percentage of people that are
infected but are asymptomatic and so
what ends up occurring here is we don't
know the actual facts about the virus
and you can't make good decisions with
bad data again I want to make it clear I
think this is serious I think that we
should take the appropriate measures if
we are going to miss on either being
overreaction or under-reaction we should
overreact to the health crisis but it is
an important conversation to have to
state that the numbers that are being
reported or inaccurate and those
inaccuracies are driving decision
makings which have a chain reaction
across the economy which are leading to
tens of millions of Americans being out
of work and hundreds of thousands of
businesses being shut down by the
government who now are not available
there's no funds available to them
because the payroll protection program
ran out of cash within a week and so
what you end
getting is this entire situation is
screwed up and it's really really sad
because again the health crisis is real
and that there are hospitals that are
being overwhelmed right a lot of people
don't know my brother is one of the
people who are treating for some of
these patients right so I've been
talking to man understanding this is
serious
but when you go to make the macro
decisions you have to have good data if
you don't have good data you can't make
good decisions and it's becoming very
very clear that the people who are
running the response especially at the
state and local levels they have no clue
a great example take Andrew Cuomo in New
York Andrew Cuomo was literally begging
and screaming and going on and on and on
about he needs 40,000 ventilators he got
nowhere near 40,000 ventilators from
both the state local and federal
government right companies were sending
that everything but they got nowhere
near 40,000 already I was a week and a
half ago already Andrew Cuomo is giving
out ventilators to other states and so
again that's not Andrew Cuomo's fault
right meaning that I don't think he's
doing anything malicious but what I do
think is that Andrew Cuomo was making
decisions on bad data the data that he
had obviously was wrong because he
thought he needed 40,000 ventilators but
now he's in a position even though he
never got 40,000 to give them away to
other states and so what I think again
needs to happen is there's got to be a
conversation around how do we get more
accurate data so that we can make good
decisions right this is not a political
issue this is both sides of the aisle or
making bad decisions by looking at bad
data and so again that then reacts or
has an impact into the economic data
that we're seeing and it's really really
bad so the other thing that I want to
talk about real quick before I start
answering some questions is the Federal
Reserve's balance sheet so as many of
you know before we got into the cove in
1980 down the federal balance sheet was
about four trillion dollars give or take
depending on exactly when you go back to
and the way to think of the balance
sheet for those that don't know is this
basically the Federal Reserve which is
the United States central bank's bank
account they've got a bank account
it's got money and assets in it and we
they have to publish every week how much
money
in there or what that total asset value
is and so it was about four trillion
dollars since that about a month ago or
so for Chilean dollars has turned into
over six trillion dollars so more than
fifty percent growth in the Federal
Reserve's balance sheet in 30 days that
means more than two trillion dollars has
been added to the Federal Reserve's
balance sheet in 30 days that's insane
especially when you look and you say
where is all of that money going out of
the two trillion dollars three hundred
fifty billion dollars allocated for
small businesses and only three percent
of the people got access to the capital
so where did the other one point seven
trillion dollars go and if you look at
things like the airlines for example
this is the this is the entire Sham of
how bailouts work if you are an investor
in the public markets or private markets
if you're an equity or debt investor and
a company came to you and said I need
capital right I have a loss in revenue I
need to keep my employees I need to keep
operating my business I want to put cash
on my balance sheet I'm willing to
either sell you equity in my business or
I will take a loan from you there is not
a single investor in the world I promise
you there's not one investor in the
world who would say I'm gonna give you
some money I might even give you
billions of dollars and I want nothing
in exchange nothing now that is what the
federal government announced earlier
this week in their airline bailout of
that industry and what I mean by that is
they literally went to a number of these
companies and they said we are going to
give you one two three billion dollars
so take Southwest for example if I
remember the numbers off top my head
correctly Southwest received 3.2 billion
dollars in the bailout of that 3.2
billion about a billion dollars they
have to pay back at a very low interest
rate lower interest rate than anyone
else would give them but the other two
billion dollars give or take they got
for nothing there are no paying it back
and there was no direct equity that was
given
as part of the loan that billion dollars
there are some warrants that are given
to the US Treasury and there are some
covenants that prevent stock buybacks
dividends and there's some rules around
executive compensation but that's on the
lending side there's a two billion
dollar grant that was given to Southwest
Airlines for nothing in exchange the
American taxpayer gave two billion
dollars to Southwest Airlines and got
nothing in exchange there's not an
investor in the world that would do that
deal United Airlines and you go all the
way through that industry they all got
similar deals like that and so what
ended up happening is rather than just
give them all money for nothing the
Treasury and others ended up getting
some value about twenty to thirty
percent of the money that they gave will
have to be paid back at low interest
rates and there may or may not be
depending on which company it is some
warrants associated with that but the US
government ended up being the idiot in
the room and those financial deals
because there wouldn't be an investor in
the world available in the equity or
debt markets that would give those
companies the same deal and so this is
what ends up occurring is that we just
bailed out Wall Street that's who we
bailed out we're not bailing out people
we're not bailing out mainstream
businesses we're bailing out the rich of
the rich who owns those companies it's
mostly really big asset management firms
and very rich people yeah of course
there's some people who own stock or
whatever it is but for the most part
those companies are owned by really rich
people and so what I believe is
happening here is we are seeing exactly
what we saw 2008 2009 exactly what we've
seen in previous crises the rich are
gonna end up getting rich or coming out
of this and the poor end up getting
poorer now where this is more apparent
than anything in the world
is if you look at the economic reality
of what's happening on the ground we
have sixteen percent unemployment in the
United States right now give or take we
have probably seventy to eighty percent
of businesses in the United States that
have been shut down by the US government
the earnings report
of many of these companies are gonna
show 50 60 70 80 percent loss in revenue
and while all this economic carnage is
going on stocks are going up there's
been more than a 50 percent retracement
in the losses from the all-time high
over the last couple of weeks why is
that occurring it all comes down to the
idea that the stock market is not a
representation of the economy the stock
market is a representation of central
bank actions smart rich people
understand how money works and the way
money works is as long as the central
bank continues to inject liquidity into
the market into the financial system
asset prices will rise as long as those
central banks inject liquidity and this
isn't happening just here in the United
States Japan recently announced up to a
trillion dollars in stimulus other
central banks are doing the same thing
so as long as central banks are willing
to continue to inject liquidity asset
prices will rocks but what you end up
getting is you end up getting a
dislocation you get asset prices rising
at the same time the economic reality is
getting worse and worse millions of
Americans every week or of filing
unemployment claims more businesses are
going out of business and not going to
come back and so that farther that that
spread gets the more likely it is that
there's going to have to be an
equilibrium found either these stock
prices are going to have to readjust to
reality or the reality is going to have
to improve to the value of those stock
prices and so what I think is going to
end up happening here is that when we
get the earnings reports a little bit
from q1 but especially for April through
June and people see entire industries
just absolutely decimated remember like
movie theaters for example the third
week in March of 2019 movie theaters did
over 200 million dollars in u.s. box
office sales just in the United States
in the third week of March 2020 they did
five thousand dollars from 200 million
to five thousand dollars in revenue in
the u.s. in a single week as an industry
when those numbers start to come out
there has to be a reality check
and what I believe is happening right
now is people are responding to the
central bank actions they're not
responding to the economic reality and
eventually reality wins right and so
that's something to continue to pay
attention to as we go
I'll start answering questions here in a
couple of seconds so just go ahead and
throw your questions in the comments the
last thing I'm gonna leave you with and
it's really important is the number one
thing that people have to remember of
how we solve all of this we have to get
testing so we can get accurate data we
have to get the economy turned back on
so we get people back to work we can get
that unemployment number down and we can
get people moving forward but all of
this is going to require hard decisions
and it's not going to be a partisan
effort it has to be bipartisan and we
have to understand that accurate data is
the backbone for all of this and until
we get that these problems are not going
to get solved so let me get I'm gonna go
all the way back to the beginning and
see if I can start answering some of
these questions leave comments I'll do
my best to work through these we've got
about 30 minutes or so that's the nice
little monologue I had there and then
we'll uh we'll go there um let's see
here to get people back to work we need
massive kovat 19 testings absolutely
that's a no-brainer pomp is an absolute
mom yeah I did not as far as I know have
any CO vid but who knows cuz a lot of
people walk around a symptomatically oh
$1200 measly bucks for ten weeks okay so
this is really important
the one time $1,200 payment started to
hit recently for Americans and there's
all kinds of rules with it I'm just over
generalize you can get up to 1,200 bucks
depending on who you are here in the
United States two things on this one
Steve mentioned basically claimed that
$1,200 could last the average family 10
weeks he's lost his mind
he's obviously out of touch with kind of
what the American family or individual
has from an expense expense standpoint
the average apartment rent on a monthly
basis in the United States about $800 so
literally you couldn't even pay two
months of rent with the $1,200 on
average and so what ends up happening
is 1,200 bucks is not gonna be enough
they're gonna have to get people more
money they already know that they're
working towards cares to act etc on top
of that there was a recent proposal by
two lawmakers that I think they call it
the emergency money to the people Act
and the idea here is that they want to
give two thousand dollars a month to
every American who makes less than one
hundred thirty thousand dollars and is
over 16 years old and they want to do
that every single month two thousand
dollars until we get back to the
employment levels pre kovat newsflash
if they enact this which there's still a
long way to go before they get to the
emergency money to the people Act being
approved if that gets enacted that is
universal basic income
there's no denying that's exactly what
that is and we will never get off of it
for two reasons first to get back to
3.5% unemployment which was a historic
low it will take an entire another bull
market to get back to that type of
unemployment and that takes years to
transpire could be up to ten years or
more in order for that to happen
and so I just don't see anyone saying
okay we're gonna give you $2,000 a month
every month for ten years and then we're
gonna take it away from you that's the
second point which is it would be
political suicide for a politician to
say to people we've been giving you
$2,000 a month every single month for
years and I'm gonna be the one to take
it away from you it's just not gonna
happen and so I think that the $1,200
one-time payment look great you got
money in people's hands it's not enough
you're gonna have to do more or you're
gonna have to get into some sort of you
bi situation if you look at Canada
they're giving I think it's like two
thousand dollars or something for four
months I may have the numbers wrong but
something like that
so kind of an in-between solution
Australia as well more money and on a
monthly basis for a preset period of
time so I think that this conversation
of univer Universal basic income is
gonna come forward 1200 bucks ain't
gonna get it done they're gonna have to
figure out something else it could be
two thousand dollars a month but once we
start true ubi where it is periodic on a
monthly basis and it's some set amount
of money I don't think we'll ever come
off of it so if you see it happened just
know we're into ubi and that's what the
United States is
let's see uh there's so many things in
here forgive dads adopt bacon so alright
so on the debt forgivable side it
wouldn't surprise me to see more
innovation happening there if you look
at like student loans for example there
was the announcement I think I think
that student loan payments have been
deferred for six months
this obviously opens up the conversation
around will we get to a point where it's
not just deferral for six months but can
we see referrals for longer periods of
time can we see interest being taken
away
can we see a true student loan like
jubilee where basically all student
loans are forgiven I don't know but but
it's definitely part of the conversation
once again once you take a step in the
water of hey we're gonna defer payments
for six months then the question becomes
well why not twelve months why not
eighteen months why do we have to pay it
back at all I think all of that is you
know something that you got to pay
attention to I'm not a doctor I'm not
going to comment on any drugs or
potential vaccines what I will say
though is more of a structural thing is
obviously if we were able to get some
sort of cure or something that could
potentially reduce symptoms or mitigate
symptoms that would be a net positive
and also could help accelerate us
getting back so testing is one piece of
getting the economy turned back on some
sort of cure would obviously be great
from a vaccine standpoint again I'm not
a doctor but what I've understood from
doctors that I've seen either writing
about it talking about or talking to
them is a vaccine is going to take
months in many cases it sounds like 12
to 18 months so that's more of kind of a
medium to long term type solution it
doesn't look like that's something
that'll happen over the next call six
months or so but again obviously some
sort of cure or vaccine would definitely
have an impact I'd help us get back to
work
more than 20% unemployment within three
weeks it scares us should I mean to say
this but I definitely think that's
possible at the rate we're going it'll
definitely happen pretty quickly here so
I think that we've got to pay attention
to that what do you think stock market
will crash or not again I don't try to
time markets as many of you know I don't
play in the public markets I just kind
of watch what happens there is a data
point on the economic reality I think
that there's a big dislocation right now
between what's happening in this
market what's happening in economic kind
of on the ground or the reality and
mainly it's just unemployment exploding
small businesses shut down every day
that small businesses are shut down is
more businesses that are not coming back
there's a really important point which
is you know my estimation right now is
that out of let's say the 75% or more
small businesses have been shut down in
America 25 percent of small businesses
are not coming back right that means
that if you had let's say 10 employees
or 20 employees and you're running a
business and you shut down and you fired
those employees those 10 to 20 employees
will not have a job to go back to when
the economy gets turned back on right if
the business itself will actually go out
of business and never return and it is a
huge problem here because if that occurs
what we will actually see is a
contraction a net loss in us-based
businesses and yes there will be plenty
of businesses that are built coming out
of this there's a lot of opportunity we
can talk some of the positives
before we go but to see a contraction in
the number of small businesses in
America will be very bad because again
it feeds into that unemployment number
there's just gonna be a loss of jobs
there won't be as many jobs to go back
to which would be a really really big
problem let's see what else here uh yes
so okay so there's people talking about
hospitals and states being paid for
diagnosis and deaths etc I don't
understand I have not done any work yet
on how the financial impact of if you
report more infections or more deaths I
do not understand it I've seen a number
of people talking about it I don't want
to comment on that stuff until I
actually have a better understanding of
it but if you weren't interested in I'm
sure you can google and find out there's
a number of people who have told me that
there is some connection between how
many diagnosis and how many deaths you
report to whether it's federal funding
or other types of funding and relief so
again I don't have an opinion there I
haven't done the work to actually
understand it but if you want to go
check that out please do and I'm sure
you guys let me know how how that works
let's see what some of the the recent
comments are are here inflation so I
don't know this is a really
controversial
pick right now right the way that what
has transpired so far is we're in a
deflationary environment what that
basically means is of the dollar has
strengthened an asset price is sold off
for a period of time in this kind of
liquidity crisis or deed trap I think
we've talked about that at nauseam now
we've now seen asset prices rise but the
dollar continues to stay pretty strong
and so the question becomes do we get
concerns of inflation hyperinflation or
do we stay in a deflationary environment
if you talk to people like Peter Brandt
or Ron Paul or Brent Johnson etc many of
them believe that we will stay in a
relatively deflationary environment and
mainly because their belief is that the
interest rates are going to go negative
etc and so we're going to stay in that
deflationary environment you'll continue
to have a strong dollar the dollar may
even strengthen over time then if you
flip around and you go and you talk to
others on the other side I don't know if
they're comfortable with me kind of
saying who they are but the number of
people on wall sure that I've talked to
who basically have said look I actually
believe that we are gonna have to weaken
the dollar systematically in order to
stabilize markets in Reverse asset
prices right kind of this idea that if
you think of it as like a seesaw as the
dollar strengthens asset prices go down
as asset prices you want them to recover
you've got a weak in the dollar both of
those scenarios are probable or are
likely to occur or can occur not nice or
likely but they can occur my guess is
that we see inflation more so I'm kind
of more in that camp than I am in the
deflation camp but the deflation that is
definitely possible to stay in that
environment and again you got to
remember that there's a lot of moving
parts here there's not kind of just one
simple explanation for this and this
leads me to this idea of there's a lot
of disagreement going on right now if
you if you talk to people in financial
markets there's tons of disagreement
some people think stocks are going up
something they're going down some people
think that gold is going up something is
going down
Bitcoin same thing right real estate oil
all these different things that
disagreement is healthy right and I
think people are forgetting markets are
made on disagreement right meaning that
if I'm a buyer and somebody else is a
seller we obviously have different
opinions about how an asset is going to
perform in the future and so that
disagreement actually creates the market
and so disagreement is healthy
especially when you have tons of
to people participating because that's
how you end up actually voting people
vote with their dollars I think that's a
really important point so when I see
disagreement that tells me that there's
markets available when you see everyone
agreeing on one side everyone's buying
assets no one's selling obviously that
market is gonna be manipulated in one
way or vice-versa like we saw with the
liquidity crisis everyone's selling not
a lot of buyers asset prices falling
kind of through the floor and so I think
that is really important to understand
that disagreements make markets and
that's actually a healthy thing how am I
getting so many people to interview
question from Chris waters it looks like
so it's pretty easy look well you know I
basically promised them three things I
say look if you come on I'm not gonna
argue with you right we'll have a
respectful conversation too we've got a
pretty big audience you'll be able to
reach a lot of people from a lot of
different disciplines and three I'm not
gonna interrupt you right I think part
of the problem that people see with the
mainstream media is or legacy media is
kind of a better term for it like
television etc is they've got a fit a
lot of content into these five or seven
minute segments and so it's very
rapid-fire ask a question you start to
answer they interrupt you you don't get
it expunged on your thoughts etc with me
what I tell people is look if you come
on I'm gonna ask you a question and I'm
gonna shut up nobody's here to listen to
me talk in terms of those interviews
right they're here to hear the guest and
so what I try to do is I try to ask
questions and shut up on what the guest
not only answer the question but also
elaborate and go into detail and explain
what they mean and really get their
point across in their work so that's
part of the beauty of podcasts and
YouTube all these things is you get to
hear directly from people in their words
and without interruption that's when I
try to do that's when I promised them
and then how do I get in contact with
them I do one of two things either
usually I'm deeming them on Twitter and
say hey you know would you be interested
in doing this or I'm getting some sort
of introduction to them so obviously
once I started to get certain types of
guests they have friends they start to
introduce me etc and so you know I think
that now it's gotten to a point where
people realize hey this would be a fun
conversation it's gonna be super
informative I'm not gonna get
interrupted I'll have a pretty big
platform in which I can share my ideas
and hopefully what will end up happening
is it'll drive a discussion on the other
end get one or two people who've got big
audiences to do that and then word kind
of spreads and so now thankfully you
know I'm going to position
where a lot of people are agreeing to to
participate and I think that that that's
kind of hopefully will continue to
reinforce itself will get bigger and
bigger guests over time so also tweeted
me let me know who you'd love to see on
the podcast I'll try to get them no
promises but we'll see how that happens
yes
Bitcoin having I'll make sure I cover on
that so look the Bitcoin having is you
know my opinion hasn't changed at all I
think that we were gonna get interest
rates going down we've now seen zero
interest rates I don't think we'd get
there but that's kind of deeper than I
thought we'd go it's looking like we may
see negative interest rates in the
United States in a sustained way and
then also the quantitative printing I
thought we'd print you know a trillion
maybe something or something like that I
think we're gonna have to do five plus
trillion now I mean that were just got
to print and print and print and print
kind of the the meme of the the money
printer goes that's exactly what's
happening here and so what ends up
occurring is you've got interest rates
at zero you've got all this quantitative
easing and people are going to be
fearful of inflation I think they're
going to seek out assets like gold like
Bitcoin etc as they move into those
assets in the United States but also
internationally there's little quantity
being injected in other markets as well
you're gonna have the Bitcoin having the
Bitcoin having essentially for those
that don't know is there's about 1800
Bitcoin created every day and dispersed
through the network in a very
programmatic way that is going to get
cut in half in May 20 2013 Thor so it'll
go from 1800 to 900 and so weak the way
to think about this is you're going to
get a demand shock meaning that more
people are going to seek an asset that
has sound like principles or in his
inflation hedge at the same time you're
going to get a supply shock where those
assets are going to become more scarce
the incoming supplier will get more
scarce I believe that as you get a
supply shock and a demand shock at the
same time it will lead to a higher US
dollar price in the future we'll see
what happens you guys all know my
position there I don't think I need to
kind of beat that horse anymore but my
opinion has it changed I think the macro
backdrop or setup here is very very kind
to Bitcoin and frankly I can't believe
that we're seeing what we're seeing but
we'll see what happens what is my
opinion on the economic effects due to
possible lingering mass surveillance
tracking face-recognition exact enacted
to beat Kovan this is a super complex
topic
so basically what you're asking here is
anytime there's a crisis
you've got to immediately turn and look
and be careful that there aren't
infringement on civil liberties or
personal freedoms we are seeing a lot of
thieves right I've talked on other
videos about things like Rhode Island
saying if you come from New York we are
going to come visit you we are going to
tell you to go back we are going to use
the military and the police to patrol
transportation hubs we saw in I feels
Kentucky a judge ordered an individual
to wear an electronic tracking device
like a GPS enabled ankle bracelet
because they wouldn't stay in quarantine
we saw a woman arrested in Raleigh North
Carolina this week during a protest
about 100 people were outside saying
it's our constitutional right open the
economy let me run my business you can't
tell me what to do that whole kind of
talk track a woman refused to go home
she didn't have a mask on except I she
ended up getting arrested by the police
we've also seen in California there was
a guy surfing they literally the the
videos hilarious Tim Kennedy and I
talked about this on the podcast we did
together they have like two or three
lifeguard and police boats chasing a
dude on a paddleboard litter he's
paddling around and there's a boat
chasing them in the ocean near the pier
and he's just like paddling around the
boat they try to catch him eventually
arrested him literally arrested him for
going in the ocean and so what ends up
happening is you know if you talk to
lawyers I did an episode with Preston
beer who is a libertarian lawyer and you
know his basic approach here is look in
times of crisis there are special powers
granted and there are certain things
that end up occurring which if you're
not a Trent lawyer you would think is a
violation of the Constitution but it's
actually not so a simple example could
be a lot of people are very upset that
churches are not allowed to actually
hold any sort of gathering and so
they're saying you can't prevent me from
practicing my faith you know the grocery
stores open but my church isn't allowed
to be opened that's a violation of the
Constitution because I am NOT being
allowed to practice my religious faith
now if you talk to a lawyer many of them
would say well actually the Constitution
the way that it's written is as long as
every single faith is not allowed to
have gatherings therefore it's not a
violation of the Constitution if we got
into a role where they said Christian
or Muslims or some other religion you
specifically and you alone are not
allowed to practice your faith that's
where you would get into the
constitutional violations I'm not a
lawyer I just try to talk to as many of
them as I can to understand their
perspective but I do think that there is
this question of constitutional
violation so you've got to pay attention
to now when it comes to the mass
surveillance and tracking duh that's
what's gonna happen right and so you see
things like Google creating this program
to basically track people on their
phones if you look in Australia I think
it was don't quote me on this but I
believe I saw an article that was
talking about people may be allowed out
of quarantine if they opt into the
electronic surveillance program like
[ __ ] that right and so in it ends up
happening as we get into this weird
world where anytime that you have a
crisis don't let a crisis go to waste is
kind of the the joke but also the truth
and so these mass surveillance tools end
up getting introduced and it's always in
the manner of hi I'm from the government
I'm here to help you as we know ends up
never going away
and so that temporary nature of it ends
up being permanent so I think that
really the way to think about this is
one you should educate yourself on
privacy right whether that is through
communications in the financial world or
otherwise the best way to fight back
right not fight back in a violent manner
in a physical manner but in terms of
your actions is to be educated and so
you know I continue to say over and over
and over again throughout this crisis
educate yourself because no one else is
looking out for you the way that you are
going to look out for yourself and I
cannot reiterate that enough you have to
take personal responsibility for
everything going on in your life do not
sit at home and say the government shut
me down and I can't make a living
because of them or my boss fired me or
I'm in this situation because of X Y Z
reason you have to take personal
responsibility that's the only way you
get out of these situations and if you
lost your job go get another one go
create a business go do something
because I agree with you it may not be
fair I agree with you that it may not
even be constitutional in some
situations but that doesn't address the
problem that you have right now and so
you can't look and play the blame game
you've got to go take the personal
responsibility and go actually solve
your problems when it comes to
surveillance and tracking same thing
you've got to be able
to be educated to understand how do I
actually want to communicate to make
sure that I'm not having my privacy
violated that I can communicate in the
manner that I want to educate it's
really important there let's see what
else here what do I think of Bill
Gates's idea of chipping people
two-track Cove in 1900 no sounds
ridiculous right one of the things that
when I was talking to more cuban one of
things that he said that i thought was
really important and very
forward-looking of him was he said look
there are surveillance or tracking
things that are going to happen and
there will be kind of erosion of privacy
and it's really just because technology
in general does this right before you
carried around a cell phone there was no
GPS you didn't carry around anything
that had GPS on this thing you started
carrying around smartphone with gps
obviously that introduces things like
location etc and so what his whole
argument was that stuff's going to
happen whether we like it or not but
where it gets really really bad and we
must fight against is this idea of
labeling right and what labeling
basically means is if you get into a
world that says hey Anthony has Co vid
but somebody else does it right you know
Sarah doesn't well what's the difference
between saying Anthony has Co vid and
there's a way to label it meaning that
either whether it's doing a chip it's
something on your phone or let's take
the historical context it's sewn into
your shirt
what is the difference or how do we
prevent them from saying that about Co
vid to something else for religion or
the way you look or your nationality or
your ethnicity or something else right
and so the idea of a labeling people
gets to be very very dangerous from a
privacy standpoint from a personal
freedom civil liberty standpoint on the
flip side there's a lot of health care
professionals who say oh but this is for
a health crisis we need to be able to
label people and track them and do all
these things in order to stop the virus
well maybe maybe that would be helpful
but just because it solves the health
crisis doesn't mean that you should
violate the personal freedoms of people
and this is where people start to enter
the complex world of reality which is
you can't do whatever you want to do to
solve your problem and just throw
caution to the wind when it comes
to the Constitution or personal
liberties and what am i you know my best
examples here is imagine if the
government said well in order to stop
terrorism we want to see everyone's bank
account we want to see all of your
communication and you guys all have to
walk her out these chips in your pocket
so that we know where you are at all
times and we can ensure that you're not
a terrorist
sure I'm sure that they've cut down on
terrorism all around the world but it
would be a violation of our liberties
and so there's a balance between solving
these problems and the liberties
I don't think putting chips in people
based on what they're actually whether
they have Kove it or not is a smart idea
it opens up a complete slippery slope
that I don't think we want to go down
let's see what else does that all the
Treasury's purchases go on the Fed
balance sheet if so is it how's it
consumed that they're working together I
don't understand that exactly what
you're asking there so maybe somebody
else can answer that in the comments
[Music]
keep putting in your questions I'll try
to do my best
do you believe housing will temporary
fall the next few months before the
dollar starts becoming systematically
devalued I'm getting a lot of questions
about real estate right now I said them
the last time I did this last week
currently my personal allocation or
financial investments or I've got cash
I've got big coin I've got real estate
and I've got a number a small number of
private investments either funds or
direct investments in companies my
belief is that the housing market is
going to be a lagging indicator meaning
that you're going to see kind of the
economic reality happen as businesses go
out of business as you get the
unemployment etc there will be a drop in
real estate prices over time I don't
think we've really seen that yet most of
these are kind of illiquid private
markets where a lot of the real estate
is done especially on the local level
and so over time we'll see real estate
drop in price but that might be still
you know six weeks three months six
months out from here but I do think that
we will see it happen I'm waiting for
that to happen and then we will what
we'll see kind of how that plays out
let's see the government want to get rid
of cash since they can't control a shake
yeah so this whole idea of like moving
to a cashless society
look there's a lot of advantages but
there's a lot of risks with it
and obviously moving to a cashless
society where there is no privacy just
creates a surveillance state you know
and I think that people just got to be
very very careful about you know kind of
how we move there and and what we have
in terms of our protections and again
the best way to be protected in those
environments is to be educated I think
that is uh the best thing to do is seed
or startup investing still a good space
look this is one of the key things you
know navall has said this before and I
think of all rava cons got a very
interesting way of looking at it but you
know for people who have high degrees or
high percentage of their net worth
invested in the early stage and startup
investing kind of private markets
private companies venture capital type
model one way to look at it is that you
can literally have hundreds or tens of
small entrepreneurial teams working to
grow your wealth right so it's very
attractive from an innovation and
technology standpoint there's also a lot
of risk right every investment can go to
zero there's no government stepping in
to bail out technology-enabled venture
backed companies right now right for the
most part and so what ends up happening
is you get high risk high rewards just
like anything that there's risk
associated with the return you can make
I think that it is still a very good
space if you look back at prior crashes
there's a lot of great businesses that
were built during economic recessions or
challenging times right with you look at
the the Twitter's that ubers the Airbnb
ease even the Facebook's to some degree
etc all of those were built during
economic downturns and so I think that
during these times basically what you
end up getting is people only are gonna
use the products that are absolute
necessities right think of just your own
spending how many things did you spend
money on you know six weeks eight weeks
ago then now also you're not spending
money on because there's not a need to
have they're nice to have but they're
not a need to have right and so what you
do is you get a washout of a bunch of
the frivolous kind of fluffy stuff and
all the only things that really remain
in times of economic downturns or the
really solid businesses they've got
great economics their value proposition
is very strong and they've got a great
way to actually acquire customers and so
if you can serve
during the bad times usually you will
thrive during the good times right and I
think that that's what we're gonna see
here is a washout of a bunch of
companies that were funded over the last
five years or so
but we will also see a bunch of
companies started right now in order to
kind of get the next crop of great
businesses because listen you gotta be
nuts right now I mean you literally got
to be nuts to start a business right and
why would you be nuts the world is
ending you know the financial markets
are falling apart there's a tons of
unemployment all the stuff well another
way to look at it is if you start a
business right now
there's tons of talent out there that
you can go get right and usually pretty
cheaper cuz there's a plethora of talent
you know that if people use your product
in some must haves not a nice to have
right and you also know it's gonna be
pretty hard for the economic situation
to get worse than it is right now and so
I actually am you know kind of leaning
into the early stage investing side
looking at a lot of these companies and
trying to pick who are the entrepreneurs
who can navigate this world who are the
entrepreneurs who are going to be able
to solve all the problems that the world
throws at them over the next six 12 18
months because if you can survive in
this downturn you will thrive in the
good time and I think that you know I
want to kind of end up here last four or
five minutes with I do believe that this
is going to end I do believe that we are
going to get through this right I think
that the way that we get through this is
to empower the entrepreneurs right we
empower the problem solvers in our
society we cannot become a society that
looks to the government to solve our
problems for us the second that we lose
the American spirit the ingenuity the
innovation the entrepreneurship that
drive that American dream the second
that goes away and we become a country
that looks to the United States
government and says we can't do it we
can't solve the problem I need you to
save me is the day that we will become a
full-on socialistic society and it is
the day that America will lose its
advantage in the world and it's because
there is no other country like the
United States in the entire world but
the United States is built on that
entrepreneurship that innovation and
that ingenuity the American spirit
drives the American dream
and that is our advantage we have to
lean into what gives us an advantage
rather than run from it if we do not
lean into that we will not only lose our
edge and our competitive advantage in
the world but we will accelerate the
downfall of the United States and if you
look today at certain situations like
there's not enough ventilators there's
not enough masks is etc where did the
help come from the government didn't
solve those problems yeah they helped
they helped in the sense of they got
money somewhere they made some orders
etc but look around the United States
and see how many companies stepped up
entrepreneurs that said I volunteer to
help do this I'm going to build that
product I'm going to solve this problem
people need help and I can provide a
solution and so what ends up happening
is entrepreneurs are problem solvers and
that's who we need to empower and so
whether it is through reducing
regulations giving them capital or
merely just getting out of their way the
way that we come out of this is by
believing in and empowering American
businesses and American entrepreneurs
and by the way if you were not born in
this country but you want to solve the
problems we should welcome you with open
arms right we should entice anyone in
the world who wants to use technology
innovation ingenuity and creativity to
come to the United States and build
companies products and services to solve
our problems because that is the
solution the way you solve unemployment
the way you solve the economic crisis in
the way you solve the health crisis is
by empowering the problem solvers to
solve problems it is not by turning to
the US government and saying please bail
me out because that is what happens in a
socialistic society and the socialistic
society is the exact 180 degrees
difference from what made America great
and so what I think that we've got to do
is we've got to empower the people who
can solve problems to do their jobs the
only way that we're gonna do that is to
restart the American economy and get
people back to work so six o'clock on
the dot
nailed it 59 minutes 50 seconds I will
do this again I'm gonna try to do this
maybe once a week I appreciate all of
you watching it would be amazing if you
could as I'm told
smash the like button that's what I keep
seeing in the comments so hit the like
button leave a comment I'll go back
later this weekend and try to answer as
many comments as I can take the URL go
tweet it do whatever you want with it
just get more people looking at this I
think that we've got a message that more
people need to hear hopefully this was
helpful hopefully it helped you
understand more about what's going in
the economy some of the questions were
great we'll do this again I hope you
guys all have a great weekend stay safe
stay alert and please continue to be
kind to each other